al quinto día del terremoto que sacudió
este lunes el sur de Turquía y al norte
sigue las cifras de fallecidos siguen
aumentando Aunque parece que en los en
las últimas horas esa cifra aumenta en
un ritmo algo más lento de lo que lo
hacía en los últimos días en los que las
cifra se disparaba a casi cada hora que
pasaba Y eso está ocurriendo porque en
algunas de las 10 provincias afectadas
en Turquía las tareas de rescate ya han
terminado es el caso por ejemplo de la
provincia de diarbaquier Aquiles o shang
de los equipos de rescate que antes
estaban destinados a estas provincias
han sido ahora destinados a otras en las
que las tareas de rescate continúan en
las que hay Aún se cree personas
atrapadas tanto si son vivas como
muertas debajo de los escombros de sus
antiguos edificios de estas provincias
son por ejemplo
a diyamangas donde estábamos hoy y la
provincia de Antioquia ahora mismo la
más afectada y que vive una citación
catastrófica es esta provincia Antioquia
la que suma ahora mismo más muertos en
Turquía